16-time grammy award winner david foster
is returning to las vegas this month
jillian lopez caught up with the
producer and singer alongside his
talented wife catherine mcphee for an
exclusive interview
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the grammys are this weekend it's a big
music weekend new year's eve
in your city in our city we're so
excited
oh hello hello catherine my wife good
how are you and cohort and singer and
extinguisher extraordinaire yeah
just asking for grammys that are in
vegas this weekend i know that's so cool
that it's
in in vegas
so my rule always was if i wasn't
nominated i never went i know that's
kind of stupid but that's my and i'm not
nominated this year uh and so i'm not
going but i i'm sure it's gonna be a
great party and what's that like to be
nominated it's good
it feels good but i know it's going to
be a party if things are pent up for you
know two years now
[Music]
let's talk about the show out here in
vegas it's coming up pretty soon what
can people expect when they come to see
both of you
well it's it's really it's his show this
is let's be honest this is david's show
he has a bunch of singers who come out
that are really amazing singers who help
sort of support um all the wonderful
songs he's written and or produced
and um
he is
unpredictable
funny
um loves to go out to the audience and i
just get to you know go out there and
sprinkle a few songs um i have this
intro for kat and the music starts and
then right before she sings i say ladies
and gentlemen katherine mcphee and the
place really does go crazy because she's
built such a legacy with you know
television shows smash and scorpion and
then waitress on broadway and not to
mention idol and and all this stuff
that's
you know it's it's it's a nice surprise
for the audience if they don't know that
she's coming well anyway that back to
you um
this show was great i mean this show is
so fun i don't know if anyone's ever
seen his pbs shows it's like
it's just such an amazing night of him
telling
really great stories of how he
discovered people how songs came to be
um and you really are just you're you're
so entertaining
just kind of as a final wrap up here
since we are heading into grammys
weekends all about the music here i'd
love to have just each of you kind of
tell me like what music means to you and
why it's so special to you
i mean music has been
such it's been the fabric of my life for
as long as i can remember i don't know i
don't even know who i'd be i didn't have
music and i've loved every
genre of music that's come along both
genres that i've i mean genres that i've
helped create and genres that i have
nothing to do with i think like today's
music i think if you the weekend bieber
shawn mendes
drake
i mean these guys are killing it they're
just i love the music i don't know how
to make that kind of music but i love it
and um
i have an open mind about it i think
that's what maybe keeps me sort of in
the mix a little bit well david
catherine thank you both so much for
taking the time this morning and i'm
just so happy for the two of you and you
have a beautiful family and
congratulations on everything and i feel
like you guys are still only just
getting started there's so much ahead so
we can't wait to have you out here in
las vegas and hey maybe we'll get to
catch up with you when you guys are here